the alien study is looking at the
genetic determinants of elite sporting
performance in particular aerobic
endurance in a measure called vo2 max
and we're looking essentially for the
fittest people in the world and we're
trying to find what in their genome was
responsible for making them that fit we
know that about 50% of the variants 50%
of what determines how fit you are comes
from your genome 50% is dreaming so we
wanted to find what that 50% is and so
we're on our global search to try and
find the fittest people to give you an
idea of just how extreme that is we have
people who have won gold medals in the
Olympics
who do not reach the criteria for
inclusion in the study so we're really
looking for the elite of the elite and
because we think that by studying these
teams we can really find something
interesting about what causes people of
them to be so extremely fit and that
should hopefully be relevant not just
for the athletes and for sporting
performance but for what we're also
interested in here in the hospital which
is heart disease